il y a la pression était forte autour de
Moscou mais sans succès la Russie a donc
annoncé il y a quelques instants se
retirer jusqu'à nouvel ordre d'Ital de
l'accord sur les céréales conclus avec
l'Ukraine l'été dernier cet accord
essentiel on va y revenir avait été
reconduit jusque là mais cette fois-ci
le Kremlin a refusé on vous retrouve à
qui a fait manuel chasse vous êtes notre
correspondante en Ukraine bonjour
Emmanuel la Russie reviendra à l'accord
quand ces conditions seront remplies dit
le Kremlin quelles sont ces conditions
et pourquoi est-ce que la Russie se
retire à présent
bonjour Pauline et bien c'est ce que
craignait la communauté internationale
Vladimir Poutine n'a pas souhaité
renouvelé cet accord un accord qui était
en cours depuis l'été dernier et qui
permettait donc à l'Ukraine d'exporter
ces céréales notamment dans les pays
africains de Vladimir Poutine avait
prévenu au cours du week-end et c'était
exprimé auprès de certains médias pour
dire que l'accord ne serait pas
renouvelé tant que les conditions russes
ne seront pas remplies ces conditions il
s'agit d'exporter les céréales russes
également ainsi que les engrais russes
et une deuxième condition c'est de
réintégrer de reconnecter la banque
russe qui s'occupe qui gère les
transactions agricoles au système de
paiement Suisse je rappelais vous la
plupart des banques russes en ont été
déconnectés cette lune des sanctions qui
a été prise à l'encontre de la Russie
pour son invasion l'an dernier à grande
échelle de l'Ukraine Bruxelles a déjà
prévenu qu'elle ne reviendrait pas sur
cette mesure et ce cet accord n'est donc
pas renouvelé on avait eu l'espoir
jusqu'au dernier moment que ça soit le
cas parce que même le président
turcréchep tahit
erdouan c'était déclaré confiant
vendredi après un appel à Vladimir
Poutine qu'une solution serait trouvée
pour l'instant ce n'est pas le cas ce
cet accord donc à ce jour n'est pas
renouvelé on connaît Emmanuel et vous
l'avez rappelé l'importance de la
production
ukrainienne pour le marché mondial de
céréales qu'elles vont être les
conséquences de la suspension ou de
l'arrêt de cet accord
alors il y a plusieurs conséquences
d'une
d'un côté il y a le code le volet
économique pour le crème l'Ukraine
l'Ukraine l'une de ses principales
richesses c'est l'agriculture c'est
aussi un exportateur l'un des principaux
exportateurs mondiaux de céréales le
fait de ne pas pouvoir exporter ses
céréales va donc poser problème à
l'économie
ukrainien problème qui est encore plus
global c'est le problème de la fin dans
le monde puisque tout simplement étant
un exportateur de poids si l'Ukraine ne
peut pas fournir notamment à ses
partenaires africains les céréales dont
elles bénéficie auparavant et bien se
posera la question des pénuries alors de
son côté Vladimir Poutine a déjà dit
qu'il proposerait d'envoyer des céréales
gratuitement à certains pays notamment
les pays qui sont le plus dans le besoin
mais du côté
ukrainien vous Vladimir zelens qui a
rencontré il y a quelques jours le
secrétaire général des Nations unies
Antonio gutherese pour parler de ce
problème pour expliquer que le crâne ne
voulait pas laisser les pays qui en ont
plus besoin justement sans céréales il
va donc falloir trouver une solution
pour écouler ce grain à la fois pour
l'Ukraine et pour les pays qui ont
besoin qui dépendent de ces imports de
céréales